guys consider yourselves modern or
traditional
modern women are traditional women
[Music]
um
identify falling this I still have a lot
of traditional
um values but I also
do have a lot of modern takes on things
so I don't I don't think I fall into
either bracket to be fair could you tell
me how are you modern and how are you
traditional so like what Traditional
Values do you have and like what about
you is modern I'm traditional in a sense
of I feel like
um women should
take care of house and home and I feel
like men should be providers of a
household
um
however I do also feel like in this day
and age
I'm not I don't really like calling
people or or any other
things like that like if you want to
whoever you want to see with who you
want to sleep with like it doesn't so
you're more modern because you're not
judgmental yeah essentially okay but you
do believe in women taking care of the
home and men going to off to work
basically no definitely I feel like
women I feel like it's as women you
should know to cook food you should know
how to clean a house you should know how
to just those basic things I think
that's forgotten a lot in this in this
day and age women don't know how to cook
food or just bait they'll know how to
drink and go out partying but don't know
how to season food or green chicken or
anything like that I think that needs
that's not something that's as common
anymore
for me I'd say I'm more traditional I
would only say a modern in the sense of
I don't like to judge people but I'm
definitely more traditional in the sense
of like you know
keeping yourself to marriage taking care
of the household the children letting
the man be the brain like um The
Breadwinner things like that
um so yeah what traditional skills do
you have
um can you sell uh yeah I can actually
say you can sell yeah I learned how to
sew when I was a kid so what else uh
cleaned the house I cook
um yeah just take care of the home
really like I'm always cleaning at home
so are you a virgin
no no not that one okay go ahead okay if
we're gonna go traditional okay go ahead
I think when it comes to matters of the
heart I'm more traditional
um what makes me a modern woman is the
fact that I'm you know pursuing a career
basically without relying on a guy
so you would
pick one
traditional you're a traditional woman
okay yeah team I'm a traditionalist
with modern gadgets
so yeah I'm not traditional I'm not
modern I'm this a traditionalist
attenter
like the traditional stuff
I tend to try and follow that way they
want to know in the chat what cultural
dishes um because everyone said they
could cook what cultural dishes can you
cook
um Frosty chicken rice Kali curry
chicken roti Dal darts
okay what traditional or what um
cultural dishes can you cook well I'm
Congolese so I'll make rice and pundu at
home and for the country these people
they'll know okay what else what else
um well a lot of Congolese is like
fondue Madison I'm not sure a lot of
people know about that unless you're
Congress yourself
um yeah it's a little right this rice
dishes also like a little pasta dishes
um yeah but okay what about you um so my
Heritage is Jamaican and British
um but my ex-husband was Colombian so I
learned a lot how to infuse so anything
from scratch really whether that's a
fried English breakfast or a pasta meal
or a chicken stew or you know any of
anything from scratch love and passion
do you think traditional women are
virgins foreign
if you're going to use if you're going
to take the word as it is then yeah yeah
no I'm not I don't think so no no what
do you think can't you I think the
traditional word for traditional women
is Virgin I think that traditional women
are virgins I'll tell you why because
traditionals putting the family before
yourself right and I think the most if
we're gonna like do the archetype of
like ideal traditional women they're
thinking about the family from the time
they're like 12 13 14 so they don't want
to have sex with anyone else because
other than their husband
because they don't want to bring that
into a marriage so if we're going to do
like the ideal archetype of like what is
the ideal traditional woman I I would
argue it's probably a virgin
I agree because they're they're thinking
Family First from like a very young age
they would never get divorced
um career really isn't first for that
like it's always family before career
everything's Family First
is there anything else you guys would
add to that that I missed
as far as being traditional yeah
I think like her attitude as well
towards her man um
yeah that's a good one then trying to
dominate or be in control even be equal
yeah it's about being able to submit to
your man your husband I think it's sex
on tap
I think that sits on tap when he wants
it as much as possible I think that's
what a lot of women will struggle with
what do you struggle with
can traditional women cheat ever no if
they're traditional then no no
yeah they're not gonna know about it
you think a traditional woman can cheat
yeah she can take care of the home and
do everything she wants an um who knows
what's going on behind closed doors you
just never know no I don't think
anyone's perfect you just never know
she could do she could be all those
things and cheap but how can a
traditional woman be a virgin if she's
got a family that's what it doesn't I
meant like a virgin on her wedding night
okay
what do you think Auntie wow that's what
I'm thinking man she said about cheating
oh wow no I don't think just because she
could I don't think she should and I
think traditionally they wouldn't
what percent of women do you think want
to be wives and what percent of women do
you think are happy being single in
today's day and age yeah and by by happy
being single means single today happy
for life being single
I think a lot more women are happy being
single nowadays
um
I'd say maybe
40 of women prefer being single 40 I
think so today's day and age and they
would rather be single than with a man
they respect and admire
okay maybe not for like 30. I feel like
a lot more women now would rather I know
a lot of women that value their career
over relationships I know a lot of women
that have not got into relationships
because they're so career driven I think
it happens more in this day and age I'd
say about yeah 30 to 40 percent okay
what do you think I'll say 20 20 and 80
want to be in relationships what do you
think
um I think if everybody's actually
really honest with themselves I think
100 percent
like you don't who wants to be single
for the rest of the last that's just
dead if you can find a guy that you can
look he will look you in your eyes and
actually say you know what I love you
and I want you to be my wife I want to
cherish you forever every woman would
lap that up unless she's a lesbian
what do you think are valid reasons for
divorce
um
consistent genuing
consistent cheating domestic abuse all
right so I'm going to make a list
consistent cheating
domestic abuse what else
um drug abuse I think the master
confused drug abuse
okay what else anything else nice
lies
okay
how many lies just one I just thought
not lies tell me when I'm out of there
okay consistent cheating domestic abuse
drugs drug abuse and lies anything else
he's if he's a psychopath like certain
mental
yeah mental illnesses I think definitely
could could divorce someone or
um poor financial
what's what I'm looking for
like gambling
gambling yeah or like they have they
don't know they can't on addiction yeah
an unhealthy addiction yeah but also one
yeah yeah in an overall
you know that question you asked Phil
about being happy being single
I think that if you
broke it into age groups it sounds it'd
be different
but if you do like
I say like the 30s and under and the 30s
over or four season under you might find
there's more unhappy women
or more women that want to get married
the older they get when they're young
they're happy being single it's only
when they're old and washed up that they
realize that oh I should have had a
man back then it still would have been
with him so I think you might find that
if you'd put an age group on it the
answers would have been different do you
think a lot of women Auntie regret
leaving their husbands in hindsight
I'll say about 75 dude really yeah three
out of four you would say regret it why
do they regret it later because they've
just done it there was no valid reason
they did it because they could or
because they didn't feel right or they
get bored or he wasn't paying attention
to me if it wants this if it's like if
somebody's life is in danger then you've
got a good reason and if there's not
then you haven't that's my view so if
you're alive for your children's life or
somebody's life is not in danger then
you've got no reason to get divorced
so everything else other than can be
worked on
I mean when you think about it if you
can get divorced for I was thinking
about this the other day if you can get
divorced for pretty much any reason like
not being happy not feeling fulfilled
he's not paying attention to me he's
never home like then why not just be in
a relationship what's the difference
like because if you're married it's
supposed to be for richer for poorer
through thick and thin it's like you're
supposed to everything but like I think
also went through that yeah I think the
Catholic church is like abuse addiction
like there's or if you know there's some
secret he was hiding that you didn't
know but when you got married but
otherwise I mean just being a
relationship like why even get married
then
um it depends on what what section
you're talking about I think I'm sure
monogamy is supposed to be a part of
marriage so I feel like if we've decided
to make
um if you decide to get married and tie
ourselves for life
I shouldn't have to accept you
consistently stepping out of the
household
um and have to deal with that throughout
our marriage yeah but I think you should
vet that before you get married yeah but
I feel like this is a nice and unspoken
rule like no one it's everyone knows
you're not supposed to cheat in a
relationship or any committed situation
unless you've decided to have an open
relationship you know when I think of
traditional women there's there's a
certain woman that and I've told this
story so many times on the pods they're
gonna but it's fine I I think of there's
there's a woman I know she's a relative
she's Catholic okay
she did not believe in divorce she would
rather die like that's when you really
meet someone with a truly traditional
mindset they would rather die than get
divorced like that there's nothing you
could tell her
and her husband
um they lived in Wisconsin and then her
husband like kind of went back and forth
he worked in Chicago he had a side chick
in Chicago like a whole girlfriend in
Chicago okay
and
that that woman she was she was Catholic
and she she like all she prayed to God
she said God please find a way to keep
my family together he left he left the
family all right for the side chick and
she prayed to God please find a solution
help us get back together
and the side chick died
amen
and he came home
and they stayed married and they never
got divorced and when I think of
traditional women that's who I think of
because she would rather die than leave
her man and like how many women have
that mindset of like
she didn't get mad that he cheated she
didn't throw it in his face she didn't
get angry over it and always bring it
back up later she genuinely tried to
find a solution understood where he was
coming from and wanted to keep the
family together no matter what now I'm
not saying you know they had a perfect
marriage or We should strive for that
but I just think like that mentality is
so rare nowadays it's like it's like
they see Instagram and they think
something's going to be better on the
other side and a lot of times it's not
about me sometimes from the where we're
sitting now the coach is here we must
know some old person
that's done that because I know a couple
and I actually know that this this guy
and I always saw him with his wife
and um who's got together and I think I
said oh he's gone somebody said where's
he gone I said oh
I said where's your husband assistant
where's your husband that's not my
husband
I was just like
okay I said someone what's their problem
everybody said that's not ours that's my
husband that's not his wife so what do
you mean they're always together it's
got doggies goes to the house we've all
up into the house you know he's like
another home and then I met the wife
the wife knew all about it but that was
her husband
and if the wife steps in and if they
happen to meet like so they were going
to a funeral and the wife was there
she had to step back and hold her place
and because the wife was the wife she
didn't they all had basically Separate
Lives you know the wife's still got the
family home grandkids and everything and
he goes and comes but their wife's got a
they always have to show respect because
she's the wife and there's no way on
Earth that she'd ever give him a divorce
that's her husband her house her
whatever he does outside but he's there
for his grandkids he's there for the
things that husband's supposed to do as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible